[Music]
we're gonna be going to joe in
washington d.c hey joe welcome to the
show
hey y'all thanks for taking the call
excited to talk to you today absolutely
how can we help
uh so i feel like i'm jumping on the
bandwagon here and uh talking more real
estate with y'all i love it yeah the
situation is that i've got an
opportunity to buy a triplex to where
i'm moving up in new york next month i'm
moving for work and
um let's say you know the worst case
scenario is it's just me in the building
right at that point it would be about 40
of my take-home pay to cover the whole
mortgage
with one tenant in there it would be
about 20 in with two tenants in there
including me i could live for free
amazing i have no other debt and i make
about 120 a year and i just i've been
looking around
i haven't really been able to see what
uh what the ramsey family insight is
into uh house hacking as the real estate
community calls it yeah house hacking
yeah we've got some of these calls
before usually they're uh how old are
you joe
i'm 32. okay usually it's younger guys
guys in their early 20s they've got no
money to their name they've got a pile
of debt and they're calling us going hey
should i do this house hacking thing i
saw it on tick tock and i can make a
bunch of money your situation's a little
bit different
yeah how much money do you have to put
down on it
um it's give me a federal loan so i'll
be going
you know real low five percent i could
put down
um you know 10 15 uh but that would be
that most of the reserves i would have
for you know maintaining the house and
you know catastrophic and is the numbers
you ran is that on a 30-year fixed rate
it is yeah okay
well that changes my answer slightly
i'm i'm not a fan of a 30-year
versus a 50. do you have any other debt
joe
do you have any debt i have no no debt
and i've got about you know
75 in in non-retirement accounts and
about 200 and uh in their time right now
okay and will you be in new york for the
long term like do you see for the
foreseeable future that's where you'll
be
uh you know the current contract is
three years so we'll oh okay what
happens in three years
oh man we just had a call so similar to
this um
in the last segment yeah when we go into
it yeah i don't know i i just for me
getting into something that
again the math you could make it work
here but i think there's just hassle and
buying something especially when it
comes to real estate in new york i'm
like
um
i don't know since you're there short
term
i don't know if i would fool with it but
george may have my personal i just
personally wouldn't do it are you is
your life going to be over if you make
this move no it's just not what i would
do it's not a the ramsay plan is we do
50 or 15-year fixed rate have a good
healthy down payment and have the
payment be no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay now you're seeing the
upside of well if i get these renters in
here that are on time that are reliable
that don't cause a lot of issues and
there's zero maintenance to do i'll be
okay
but when i look at it i also see a whole
bunch of risk involved
and i'm never gonna steer someone
towards a 30-year fixed rate because joe
you're 32 you have a long full life
ahead of you i don't want you to be tied
down with a mortgage and i know people
say well rachel they're paying they're
paying the mortgage for me it's free
nothing in life is free when it comes to
real estate there's always going to be
maintenance repairs you you've got the
mortgage property taxes insurance you
name it extra liability with these
tenants so if you can swing it on a
15-year fixed rate and you had the same
numbers i'd go okay i feel a lot better
about that if you had a healthy down
payment i'd go i feel better about that
but at the numbers you you gave me it
makes me uncomfortable you're just right
on that line joe a little bit of like oh
i could go it could go south really
quick and you're gonna regret doing it
would you cash out the 75 non-retirement
to do it
i don't think so because then you know
i'm writing strictly on
uh just on my monthly and coming online
on my w-2 so you're the 75 is what
you're seeing
you're saying the 75 is your reserves
yes but it's currently invested
it's in you know it's in mutual funds
just like regular uh you know highway
liquid mutual funds yeah i mean if you
cashed it out and that became your down
payment you could do a 15 year i'd feel
a lot more like there's a lot more
breathing room for you
so that's what i would do personally
again we treat calls what we would do if
i woke up in your shoes and that's what
i would personally do yep there's just a
lot of factors and i know it sounds
exciting and kind of like oh cool okay i
could get this and this and this and
this and it would work so well and could
it work absolutely it could but also it
could go downhill real quick so
if you were to do it it would be on a
15-year fixed rate mortgage
uh yeah with no more um or with a bigger
down payment so i would put down yeah 10
to 15 percent there and then you'd got
to just be real sure that you'd get them
that you'd get roommates in there but
hopefully that would lower the
percentage of what you would your
mortgage of what you would pay but all
all of the math needs to work really
well
for us to feel good about it or you're
just dealing with a lot of hassle and
you could be a little bit hassle free